pop
[Musique]
post6 friedli un biface l'anglais
oh
où
mon
[Musique]
franche et la diane portman
la réponse de mon mari il est consentant
ils acceptent de reprendre la vie
commune système jeunes anarchistes vous
matin chez lui en france au domicile
conjugal
une lettre est bien touchante
il prend l'engagement d'être fidèle et
affectueux cet écrit était sincère je
n'en demande pas tant
j'ai sur lui des droits considérer
d'abord votre devoir d'épousé les
couples unis par dieu leçon pour la vie
entière
c'est bien mon avis je prends le train
j'y vais sans amertume ou rosa sans
maurice pons et la générosité du partout
je laime encore c'est bien certain
liebman man
et à l'amphithéâtre mêmes briefings mal
mais quand même ma fille et moi nous
prions dieu de vous accorder la paix du
coeur auprès d'anne et pour bien aimé il
sera le casa dervier pour mme attendant
l'arrivée du train nous allons nous
retrouver comme nous nous sommes quittés
sur un quai de gare
après 18 ans de séparation c'était la
guerre aux il est français
vous êtes allemande n'oubliez pas
or je n'oublie rien mais pourquoi avoir
choisi verviers pour cette rencontre
il viendra me chercher à la frontière
avec sa voiture
je veux aller vers toi pour t'accueillir
sur la terre de france
votre mari est un homme grande
délicatesse de sentiments ils méritent
votre indulgence
j'ai eu la bonté d'âme et aussi la
patience aux marguerites friedrich
chanteuse allemand né à berlin en 1901
morte assassinée près de verviers dans
la région des fagnes en 1957 la porte du
crime n'est pas entière car le corps ne
fut jamais retrouvé
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un au salon une malle ça vient
d'allemagne
par le train en petite vitesse c'est un
long voyage
on peut voir la patronne la patronne à
la migraine elle repose puisqu'elle
repose
laissons la zone et ont passé un peu
plus d'un la route de mons est un vrai
talent qu 5 km pour venir et autant pour
rentrer votre colis vous dirai
chercheurs but on le ramène à la gare je
suis bestioles de bonne volonté mais en
une circonstance lui il ne porte une que
je puisse faire je vous le demande
avait il à battre en effet de la signer
sa chambre dans les étages
la date est son nom
on vous attend et il ya des frais
quelque chose appelée même pas ces
francos vous avez un crayon alors je
monte
si vous voulez vous rafraîchir messieurs
la bouteille sur le comptoir et le coeur
sur la main
olga petit matin
on vous demande au salon
avec des gens comme ça faut s'étonner de
rien la patronne vous prie de croire à
sa reconnaissance je vous rapporte le
papier signé certifié sincère et
véritable
voici votre crayon tout est en ordre
bonne chance messieurs et courage pour
votre au dur labeur
je n'ai pas de monnaie mais vous avez
vidé la bouteille lorsqu'on a bu le
pourboire est inutile messieurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est
la société nationale des chemins de fer
français de subalterne
on livre à domicile une belle geci a
déchargé à régler cette affaire comprend
pas ton bagage est arrivé 32 kg même qui
vient de hambourg en doute chaude
madame aux réserves par madame rose est
madame olga manoir comtesse trop de
monde j'aime allegri mais c'est écrire
rose plein snav
c'est pour madame la snel n'était quête
faut savoir la lire jusqu'au bout
voilà ce qu'on s'est trompé c'est une
erreur une erreur de la sncf aurait dû
signer g6 et à table est profonde
je ne pouvais pas savoir
j'ai cru d'attenté un colis je m'appelle
je fais pour le mieux mais pas
d'histoire je vais pas qu'on fait des
histoires
une femme seule avec un commerce tout le
reprends ta folie petit mais comme tu
vois ta folie provoqué non on le rendra
sa destinataire acquis
eva cette madame
rosales de la cote comme c'était greer
on finira bien par la route et par ben
je vais manger league
tiens j'ai mon camarade de théâtre la
salle
eh ben il doit bien savoir si dans sa
famille il ya une dame 11ème avec
renault sas aux élèves non non non non
non sucette pas tout fait de la peine
moi j'avais l'habitude de bombay ne
serait pas tient demain il ya une
représentation au collège saint-joseph
j'ai retrouvé mon vol ce qui poserait la
question qui s'est tu vas pas le cem le
frère bull est d'acheter brasseur
audemar connais bien mené ce thème tout
cas mais pas de colis en plein milieu de
mon plancher il faut que la maison reste
coquette concept mal format ça dans le
cagibi à la disposition de ces
propriétaires et 32 kg
aller s'asseoir derrière la ferrari
l'allant voilà mon président disparaît
et crasseux tout je te pas plus alors
monsieur 700 promenade
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
mariage de madame rosa friedrich avec
monsieur paul nas 9 amsterdam le 14
janvier 30
en 45 minutes ouais semble aussi ouvert
la clovis ses vols ouais on commence à
un ennemi ou car tout le monde sur le
plateau costumes et maquillages il ya
cet après midi des chahuteurs dans la
salle du terrain la consigne on enchaîne
quoi qu'il arrive il arrive ça l'est
dans la salle pour vous at on déclaré
louis clovis pensionnaires des scènes
subventionnées
[Musique]
ce qu'on doit respecter dans le mariage
c'est la généralité des principes
un homme et une femme s'engage dans la
voie de la fidélité réciproque de
l'assistance réciproque de l'affection
réciproque à la mairie cet engagement et
cela même certes acquis paris tu as toi
je suis pour l'engagement conjugales
mais je n'ignore pas non plus que
l'union libre peut-être une forme
évoluée de cet engagement
il est fréquent de rencontrer parmi les
artistes artistes laisse moi rire tu
vois de la pharmacie et moi les
chaussures nous sommes des amateurs
nous jouons par vocation pour nous le
théâtre n'est pas un métier mais le plus
beau des bastaings dire la question
n'est pas si justement je suis une
commerçante et je tiens à conserver la
clientèle
madeleine tout à l'heure nous allons
monter sur les planches et après les
temps de nous recueillir
je suis une femme qu'on dépose si
vraiment en plein temps sur le deux
mariés c'est facile va à la mairie va à
l'église à nous un jeu ne se lance pas
dans le mariage sans un moment de
réflexion un moment de réflexion
voilà cinq ans que tu réfléchis
stéphanois n'est pas si fort mais nous
sommes dans un établissement religieux
de la mort propos moins de plaisir
sylla a précédé dans ce pouvoir suprême
le brand césar mon père on a joui de
même dans un si différent tous deux
l'ont regardé le lin sont des délits et
l'autre dada raté mais la rue est
barbare est mort et mais tranquille
comme un bon citoyen dans le sein de sa
bible l'hôte tout et bonnet ont eu lieu
du sénat a tranché
assassinat
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu fais là je cherche ma
subsistance dans les collèges l'artiste
n'est pas prêt ghsr mais les nourrit
gillon tu as peu destine pour ton vieux
père fille est celle là peut s'appeler
la gratitude car j'ai été élevé dans les
temps difficiles à paris je voulais
quand hier je suis resté à leva pour le
bien de mon enfant sous bientôt
la vie est peu de chose et le peu qu'ils
t'en reste ne vaut pas l'acheter par un
prix si funeste meurt mais quitte du
moins l'avis avec éclat et un an le
flambeau dans le sens de l'ingrat à toi
même en mourant immole ce perfide
contentant ses désirs punissons
parricide fait un tourment pour lui de
ton propre et pas entre eux sans qu'ils
le voient et non je dis cela je me sens
plus tôt nous mêmes de ce que vous
attendez que nous soyons encore le
spectacle dans la coulisse on déjoue
marivaux en écoutant corner ma fille est
au parloir des vents merci j'ajoute
qu'elle a besoin de consolation
qui a eu de moi je suis pas celui ci
aussi ce que l'islam vers l'as marck a
du fric germain fils de son père joli
garçon grosses fortunes
bompas et du pape pour le droit je le
reconnais il ya pas de moralité dans les
familles nécessiteuses
on me trahis
pourquoi pleurer vous
si malheureuse malheureuse c'est tout
j'ai voulu vous abordez les fleurs
sont enveloppés comme si vous aviez août
si tout le monde me connaît sait fait
mes études au collège avait reçu une
bonne éducation
on apporte des fleurs aux comédiennes la
coutume je ne suis pas une comédienne je
suis la fille d'à malhonnête
c
le français
alors ce mariage dont on parle
je pousse presse tu parais
comprend ma situation c'est dévié
artistes impétueux brabbi end c'est un
problème parce que bien sûr que je suis
la nasse pourquoi pas alors à quand le
mariage tu seras prévenu est un obstacle
c'est pas une femme qu'on laisse tomber
j'aimerais vous mariez moi ça me ferait
plaisir
bref ça ferait plaisir wenger tous les
deux enfin la clémence et la plus belle
marque d'un sac
[Applaudissements]
d'où me vient cette joie et que mal à
propos mon esprit malgré soi boutin
entier repos c'est armand destination me
donnait dallas mon coeur et s'inspire
mes yeux nettement dollar reste quelque
chose à te demander tu auras ton vengeur
tout à l'heure merci le cachet convenu
pour toi et tes fiches n'ai pas les
moyens de le montrer généreux
la cour
quelque chose amsterdam amsterdam ça te
dit quelque chose
la patrie de spinoza j'ai vécu des
années difficiles les groupes de femmes
et la maison de rembrandt du cannet la
maison de rembrandt l'usure avec des
graves a gardé le souvenir du musée
enfin dans l'ensemble dus à conserver
d'amsterdam souvenirs à gré
quand vous le voulez que je meure avec
ce grand courage qui passe et
entreprendre ce sera dans la même
assiette
la comparaison avec des troupes
professionnelles venues de paris est
tout à votre avantage monsieur là cela
les je veux vous féliciter vous et les
chairs interprète qui vous entourent
pour la qualité vraiment artistique de
cette représentation
à votre santé
ce champagne nous paraît d'autant plus
savoureux que nous sommes la
représentation terminée on est à 1
florrick c'est la juste récompense un si
bel effort dans l'art d'interpréter le
verre classique vous en avez de la
mémoire mais toujours assez difficile
d'expliquer ce phénomène de la mémoire
chez l'artiste dramatique car non
seulement un rôle doit être reçue sans
la plus légère défaillance mais il faut
encore à chaque instant avoir le souci
de la diction et du maintien
tu ne bois pas j'attends qu'on m'invite
un pro séries comme jade a plein le
temps des fiançailles quelle époque
quelle époque d'incertitude la fameuse
théorique soutient monsieur diderot
paradoxe de médias et bien je
je vous prie de bien vouloir m'excuser
supérieur un incident sans gravité
je dois te rappeler à la bienséance nous
sommes invités tu pars en quatre ans la
porte et curé ils éprouvent de la gêne a
salué sa concubine fois de comprendre le
mariage est pour bientôt on le sait
bonsoir
après officier les conséquences peuvent
être graves
le supérieur appartient à la
congrégation diocésaine et nous jouons
dans les institutions religieuses du
département
j'ai droit à des égards je te promets
réparation je ne crois plus à des
promesses qu un instant si tu
m'accompagnes je suis très surpris de la
bonne volonté de ceux publics en
français y sont vraiment 13 même ils ont
l'air de s'intéresser à la tragédie
classique
monsieur supérieur je tiens à profiter
de cette aimable cérémonie vous annoncer
mes fiançailles avec mademoiselle goût
villon aux fiançailles
nous allons nous marier c'est bien notre
intention
si c'est là un engagement solennel
croyez certes que je m'en félicite
c'est la signification je pense que vous
souhaitez donner à cette présentation
officielle il ne nous reste plus
monsieur supérieur qu'à fixer la date de
la cérémonie
je comprends votre impatience
nous nous marierons à l'automne me sera
extrêmement agréable d'accueillir dans
ce collège la compagnie dramatique de
monsieur madame paule l'asnav nous avons
une salle de théâtre moderne et bien
aménagé mais je ne vous cacherai pas que
la promiscuité de la coulisse m'inquiète
quelques fois votre mariage est à tous
égards une ruse solution ouais j'ai vécu
à l'année est en déficit
je ne regrette en rien dans une époque
où le bien-être conduire renoncement à
l'abandon je reste un homme de caractère
tiens le coup possible disait mon vieux
maître il faut savoir attendre et après
on dit sienne je suis toujours là et
j'attends encore
tiens rentrer à la maison et pouvoir
l'asu sheila compte un seul gars pour
mes affaires
alors pioche le jardin il doit bien y
rester encore quelques les yeux
elizabeth d'angleterre mais toi tu ce
monde où s'agitent historienne ont joué
dans des grands et salut
mais l'artiste valérie crois qu'elle le
fait remarquer l'épaule shakespeare
s'expire et c'est mon camarade
à bientôt si ni excuse moi mais je suis
animé du souffle dramatique
alors bon dieu que je vous ai ne vaut
pas mieux petrov s'est fait de parler
comme ça va te coucher génie un homme
qui avait tu comme un indigent artistes
professionnels madame gta l'a fait sur
les boulevards
j'ai fréquenté les plus mal les
célébrités de l'eldorado bien moi
monsieur je suis une femme qui a
toujours travaillé j'ai 58 ans et je
rentre à pied des mots toujours des mots
cette bouteille sinon pour les enfants
des tur et avec des amateurs
ça ne peut plus durer le gall votre hôte
ma chance au cinématographe artistes
complémentaires mais intelligent le
train rapide pour paris-nord je prends
le 22h30 à côte les maillages aller j'ai
touché mon enveloppe ont caché celui de
la fille de conflit un ticket en
soufflet de deuxième classe
olga je quitte la province est en guerre
je te dis que je retourne à la capitale
a une fois de plus
adieu le gard arazi l'on est à propos
j'ai posé la question à voile la bombe à
damas m oui rosales l'année passée c'est
une parente à lui qui visitent
l'allemagne peut-elle envoyé cette manne
à mon adresse alors non pas ton adresse
à celle de ton prédécesseur monsieur
deux buts
oui j'étais une amie de chaptelat mai
mais ça fait partie des ces mots voilà
l'explication du quiproquo
qu'est ce que j'en sais moi de cette
malle normal moi c'est pas la france ni
même pas le but en or a conduit par
mafia locale nous vous posons donc assez
- thurella lui porter ces salles je m'en
charge les bateaux tous les tons et il
disait dès mon retour gérer la liban
soit là demain sous cette photographie
serait la preuve pertinente est
recevable en droit du mariage à
amsterdam en 1938 de paul le snarr avec
une personne frédéric robin rosa
friedrich jeudi je lis voilà est
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre il épouse sa
concubine madeleine gouvy on s'est
décidé il en a pris l'engagement devant
l'autorité ecclésiastique en ma présence
que veux tu que je te réponds tu ton
instinct vite idiot si vraiment il est
marine peut pas s'en sortir à l'homme
sur le retour
accablé par sa passion il aime sa
maîtresse et pour la conserver il
n'hésite pas à promettre la possible une
histoire de province est ridicule sans
intérêt tu ne comprends pas très bien la
situation
l'asnav ne peut que faire durer il
tergiverse pour profiter des faveurs de
saddam une petite mignonne dont il est
amoureux
aucun rapport madeleine est une créature
souveraine de la prestance et du
caractère un le jour où elle sent un
copeau l'aider à marier je la crois
capable de l'étriper bons ballons comme
des gens d'affaires
assieds toi tu as fait le voyage de
paris
tu es ici qu'est ce que tu veux eh bien
je te connais le soin d'aller trouver
paul dans sa pharmacie du maître le
marché en main la forte somme on les
sons de notre discrétion
chantage je m'emballe compte
et pourquoi pas seulement mon cher une
un chantage c'est une entreprise
cadreuse qu'il faut savoir manier amiens
par la charge c'est peut-être marié en
1938 à amsterdam mais entre temps la
petite boursiers il est plein de boeuf
je le saurai pas rien du tout sipa les
livres il épouse madeleine qui l'en
empêche
mais paul vi dans l' angoisse c'est un
homme traqué cette femme le cas je te
dis et pour elle et s'exposent au mépris
à la honte au déshonneur public devant
lui le ouf s'y précipitent destin
tragique non pour faire chanter
il faut être sûr de son motif je me dis
qu'il est marié peut-être c'est en
apporte la preuve
une des photos une dame rose à la
hollande avant la guerre on sert à mai
tu as devant toi le spectacle de la
déchéance une franchise répondre à 66
ans le seuil de la honte
il n'était dans la nécessité louis
clovis est à bout de ressources et je
sais que si je joue au théâtre un cachet
puis un autre et moi je besogne il
n'enquête une filature mais seulement
pêche pas de réfléchir
la seule chose à faire c'est de tâter le
terrain
je vais écrire une lettre à ce monsieur
par l'asnav a même nom je signe
rosa ta femme avant qu'un viol est le
style d'une épouse délaissée toi sur le
veille le personnage à l'heure du
courrier il est commerçant c'est facile
d'entrer dans sa boutique tâche de
connaître sa réaction s'il fait vilaine
figure
j'engage la négociation seulement s'il
fait vilaine figure et bien sûr on
partage le bénéfice moitié-moitié
moncharline je suis bien étonnés
d'apprendre la nouvelle de ton
chamaillard
avec la femme gouvion vivre
votre bonne amie est tout de même une
façon bien personnelle de tenir un
commerce elles ferment boutique à mardi
à 10 heures du matin c'est le jour de
sol sont là félicite de pouvoir se payer
une voiture
moi je marche à pied d'un programme gens
vous semblez bien mais pourtant ça c'est
une bêtise d'un crédit sans doute mais
vous parlez sans savoir une porte
question d'acheter une voiture alors
pourquoi apprendre et à la conduire pour
se distraire et s'amuser
c'est une fantaisie mon propre a pas
tout ça me regarde je ne suis pas jaloux
du moniteur d'hôtes ou quoi
allez faire un tour dans les petites
rues derrière la cathédrale c'est par là
qu'on apprend la marche arrière
là où sans brutalité une halte doucement
très doucement
laissez vous aller
merci
tabac d'orient
pour rêver
en voiture c'est un peu comme un nid
d'amour qu'est ce qu'on attend
alors comme ça vous avez décidé
d'apprendre à conduire je vais passer
mon permis
la province n'est pas très riche en
distraction il faut savoir trouver son
partenaire
je ne comprends pas du tout ce que vous
voulez dire
une jolie fille comme vous avec un
commis en pharmacie mois les analyses me
répugne ray messieurs paul l'asnav est
un artiste
ah oui le théâtre est d'apprendre
déroule parker ça vous amuse de les
apprendre peut-être pas mais de les
jouer certainement alentours de
m'expliquer sincèrement je vous ai
rencontré je crois vivre un rêve
l'ademe vous êtes la femme de meuf
g
très touchant ce matin-là le sera
terminé voulez-vous m'ouvrir la porte je
peux descendre
non sérieusement madeleine toi et moi on
est fait pour cent entre les baumes
lâcher
[Musique]
c'est maintenant sur la voie publique
que tu te donne en spectacle je dois te
faire souvenir que nous portons
maintenant passer votre chemin
il ya entre nous
le sujet de famille tu dois m'entendre
et d'ailleurs que tu vas m'entendre
j'aimerais savoir si tu as encore
conscience de ses responsabilités
qu'est ce que tu cherches un scandale
je suis un clown mains [ __ ] je crise
je ne compte pas si malheureusement
parce que tu es mon frère une fois quand
on prend le même monde
j'en conviens mais nous habitons une
ville où les nouvelles circulent je
reviens de l'évêché on me dit que tu es
pusta médecin qu'est ce que ça signifie
jupons madeleine de l'amour et du
respect où est la solution telle demande
je suis prêt à jeter son magasin
rentre chez toi en brosse ta femme tu le
présentera mon bon souvenir d'une
personne distingué avec elle tu n'es pas
n'importe qui
tu devrais te surveiller davantage tes
paroles sont navrantes et déraisonnable
et puis vite de courir après les
voitures automobiles
c'est le comportement d'un à l'ailé tu
veux me faire enfermer
ma place est à l'asile je suis marqué
pour disparaître
et quand on a de l'argent tout devient
possible
monsieur julien l'asnav mon frère vous
êtes ignobles
ignoble
puisque monsieur julien est rentré
suis pas curieux de directeur
une apparu ton père
il est allé voir le maire
[Applaudissements]
voulez vous nous laissez s'il vous plaît
je voudrais prendre de l'argent sur mon
compte
longuet
3000 francs
pareil pas rien dans une caisse à la
signature de monsieur julien j'ai dit
sur mon compte je comprends bien mais
pour vous donner la somme je suis
obligée d'emprunter sur la recette et je
ne peux pas le faire sont la signature
de monsieur julien dommage pour moi très
bien vous êtes agréable monsieur raymond
mais l'opération ça et régulier mais je
suis comptable
elle
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré quand il a fléchi somme
il est chez moi si ça ne m'étonne pas
c'est un grand bonhomme on passe à table
en fait il vous servir mon pote de
musique pendant les repas se ferait tuer
retire cette blouse on se parle chez
l'épicier ses comptes les tonneaux selon
l'ong à présent plus qu'en de laver les
mains un jeune le potage monsieur les
presser madame et monsieur mange
beaucoup trop vite je peux plus les
suivre
on n'est pas là avec tous dans son
bureau
c'est inattendu il travaille c'est parce
que tu avais le travail et les permis à
raymond ne s'intéressait à la bonne
marche de la faire enfin je le pense
mais quel choc rech il va très bien
julien dumas somme et oui tu m'as somme
ce genre de réflexion me désobligeants
vraiment et mon frère je pourrais t'en
souvenir
bon appétit
1 c'est vrai j'oubliais et fait même pas
tapioca aux jeunes non laisse je n'ai
pas faim qu'est ce que tu faisais source
j'ai emprunté sur mon compte c'est
permis non c'est de l'argent
la caisse il m'a confié la caisse
qu'est ce que tu aurais vraiment je t'en
prie numérique vous je suis ici dans la
maison de mon père j'ai de l'argent la
brasserie temps comptes figurent au
capitaine tu l'as pas dans les douches
et ses conversations d'intérêt sont
infiniment pénible moi aussi j'ai besoin
de 3000 francs ça recommence les parties
de poker raymond n'est plus un enfant tu
pourrais comprendre
mon cher mari je suis curieuse de savoir
comment tu vas t'y prendre pour devenir
bigame voici à toutes fins utiles le
texte de l'article que j'ai l'intention
de faire publier dans la presse locale
et régionale avec expédition d'un
exemplaire personnels et particuliers
petits tas au supérieur du collège
saint-joseph petit b o l'asnav de la
brasserie petit c'est à ta fiancée
madeleine goupillon madame rosa
friedrich l'asnav épouse de monsieur
paul l'asnav préparateur en pharmacie
s'indigne des promesses matrimoniale
faite par son mari à mademoiselle
millions et tient à mettre en garde les
personnes de bonne foi contre les
manoeuvres rosen délicate de sept
individus sans scrupule
elle fait toutes réserves en ce qui
concerne ses droits des pousses délaissé
qu'elle se propose de faire valoir ou
alors du pays je t'envoie mon avocat
pour négocier un arrangement
tu as toujours été une saleté et puisque
l'occasion m'est offerte d'obtenir une
compensation je ne vais pas la manquer
ta femme restée fidèle par delà les
années
rosa
au paul je suis rentré pour t'acheter de
l'aspirine
c'est la panique l'époux vente l'horreur
il a besoin des murs pour retrouver son
équilibre en regard de paix très cul
madame friedrich est morte assassinée né
à berlin
c'était une chanteuse d' assez médiocre
conditions le 15 septembre 1957 elle
quitte la maison des dames schiller à
hambourg pour rejoindre en france son
mari pour l'asnav dont elle est séparée
depuis la guerre je n'arrive nulle part
on perd sa trace
elle avait 56 ans a le vin petite ville
du nord les l'asnav c'est toute une
famille
le chef d'abord julien qui dirige une
brasserie girondins leur fils germain
raymond 24 arte le frère de marthe un
inutile de bonne éducation et besoins
des 3000 francs et voici paul l'asnav le
frère de julien le mari de la chanteuse
allemande qui se contentent d'un emploi
plus modestes
il est le préparateur de madame pincemin
la pharmacienne les jours de la semaine
on le trouve en blouse blanche dans son
magasin le dimanche ils jouent les
empereur de rome sur la scène d'un
patronage et madeleine goupillon lui
donne la réplique
elle se prétend et se croient depuis
cinq ans sa fiancée
je suis une femme qu'on dépose le
mariage est décidé pour l'asnav en a
pris l'engagement devant le supérieur du
collège
il ne nous reste plus monsieur supérieur
qu'à fixer la date de la cérémonie
je comprends votre impatience nous nous
marions
à l'automne dont la save et idiot c'est
vraiment il est marié ne peut pas s'en
sortir
louis clovis mène à le vin une existence
difficile
il habite avec sa fille anne-marie une
triste maison la route de mons c'est un
vieux comédien avec tout un passé de
malchance et de déception mais
l'histoire commence vraiment concept mal
arrive de hambourg
l'étiquette porte l'adresse de rosa
friedrich au manoir comtesse une demeure
prétendu historique transformé pour les
besoins du commerce de madame olga en
bar américain
clovis parce qu'il est curieux fait
l'inventaire du colis ce ne sont que
précieuses reliques des oripeaux qui
évoque la gloire tapageuse d'une
chanteuse de cabaret et aussi dans son
cadre la photo d'un repas de noces
clovis prend la photo il la met dans sa
poche et il vient à paris consulté
pitois l'avocat des affaires douteuses
la discrétion possède une valeur
marchande
il s'agit seulement de savoir en
négocier le prix et bientôt une lettre
prévient paul l'asnav de la visite de
putois
le préparateur en pharmacie se comporte
comme un coupable par avance il accepte
tout déjà il est prêt à payer pour
éviter le scandale
car on va connaître par toute la ville
que le préparateur de la pharmacie est
un triste personnage qui abusent de la
crédulité des jeunes femmes trop naïve
et sincères dans leur affection
[Musique]
je vais vous recevoir dans ma chambre
monsieur est un vieux camarade artiste
lyrique
[Applaudissements]
alors cher monsieur vous abandonnez
madame l'asnav ou la laisser pendant des
années son nouvel sans argent ça n'est
tout de même pas très régulier n'est ce
pas contre nous vous auriez pu l'idée un
peu parce qu'elle a beaucoup souffert
cette pauvre femme à qui je meurs de
parler je possède délégation légal pour
agir au mieux des intérêts de votre
épouse
je vous écoute
la cliente vous a adressé une lettre les
termes en sont je crois assez précis
madame l'asnav vous propose une solution
compensatrice car bien sûr nous sommes
en droit de faire enquête auprès des
tribunaux de tribunaux allemands
conformément à la loi du 29 juillet 1881
le parlement je vois bien je suis
ressorti sans fenêtre de ma femme
devient pas non plus d'allemagne il
porte cachée de la rue du louvre à paris
ça vous étonne
absolument je remarque sur vos doigts
j'ai un train dans 53 minutes
alors s'il vous plaît ne chicanons pas
ses cinquante mille cash nouveau franc
bien entendu 52,5 millions je dois payer
5 millions
cher monsieur vous êtes en situation
fausses notes moselle goupillon serait
en droit de porter plainte pour abus de
confiance
elle le fera si je lui en donne le
conseil
excusez moi mais c'est mon métier je
n'ai pas d'argent
je voyais ma vie modestement
qu'est ce que vous cherchez mes fiches
de paye
mademoiselle goupillon habite la maison
d'en face
je vais avoir davantage de faire sa
connaissance
laissez moi ce plaisir c'est une très
jolie femme
le monsieur je n'ai pas 5 millions je
puis vous communiquer le chiffre de mon
solde créditeur
vous constaterez que je suis sans
fortune monsieur l'asnav quand il faut
payer on trouve l'argent je vous laisse
quatre jours quatre jours c'est
amplement suffisant si vous êtes de
bonne volonté
j'accepte de pilule mais par mensualités
5 millions dans quatre jours je m'en
voudrais d'assister sur les conséquences
d'un refus vous avez largement profiter
des avantages d'une situation
compromettante
alors faites l'effort vous exiger de moi
une somme exorbitante en billets usagés
de préférence par liasse de 10000 cela
ne constitue pas un trop lourd pack et
vous serez avertis par téléphone du
vieux fixé pour la rencontre je vous
engage à vous conformer scrupuleusement
aux instructions qui vous seront
transmises dans votre intérêt
ne conduisez pas je passe toujours
inaperçu
[Musique]
tu as répondu au téléphone
c'est beau comme vertu et nourris
j'avais dit à l'aise respectable
il dit toujours des bétis
[Musique]
elle marie
je
amari
j'ai ma moto vous faites un tour avec
moi non mon père est parti en apportant
la clé il n'est pas là je l'attends
j'ai acheté des cigarettes fumées
non merci
quand je vous ai appelé vous n'avez pas
répondu je ne voulais pas répondre
cet idiot j'allais m'en aller
je suis passé devant la maison sans la
voir alors j'ai continué jusqu'à
l'église de croix et puis je suis revenu
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que cette baignoire
nous habitons dans un chantier de
vieilles démolition c'est assez triste
hiver surtout la campagne d'hiver c'est
toujours triste
ici ce n'est pas la ville et ce n'est
pas non plus la campagne c'est nulle
part quelqu'un peut passer sur la route
de mons et s'arrêter moi par exemple je
suis venu fait la charité d'âge les
sentiments savez bon coeur
[Musique]
le soir venu les gars on cherche des
filles pour les embrasser et quand il ya
des fossés c'est encore mieux
l'autre jour au collège
vous avez apporté un bouquet de
pâquerettes germain l'asnav avec une
fille de la route de vence réfléchissez
de quoi auriez-vous l'air vous êtes
jolie vous ne savez pas
elle voulait pas sourire à quoi à
l'amour
vous m'en voulais
ça n'a vraiment aucune importance quel
âge avez-vous âneries je suis une
vieille de 18 ans dommage tout est
forcément gâcher d' avance avec un père
comme le mien qu'est ce que je peux
devenir si vous croyez que ma vie est
heureuse ce n'est pas tout à fait pareil
je vous assure
chez nous il ya trois voitures
la cuisinière et les vacances en
normandie mais pour ce qui est de
l'affection on peut s'interroger c'est
plein de vieilles rancunes ma famille
quand on sait bien disputer ma mère
pique sa crise
et cela il va te coucher là bas cinq
heures tous les jours on peut se
demander pourquoi la première équipe
commence à 5 heures je dois être là ça
n'est pas de personnes tu sais pas même
théorisé ce qui les aiderait davantage
ce serait d'apprendre qu'un homme de 35
ans normalement constitué stoli chaque
matin j'appartiens à la population en
nocturne
j'ai davantage de contempler les étoiles
avec les employés de chemin de fer et
les permanents des ptt
pendant que tu roupies conversation me
semble passablement d'idiote où tu pas
dans un état de nerfs à la supporter je
monte
monsieur germain n'est pas rentré oui
madame
l'aurait-il tard sûrement ton fils
traînent dans les rues sur une
motocyclette tu le dis rien je tue c'est
un jeune homme je suis sans doute
stupide mais germar encore besoin d'être
surveillés
je n'aime pas ça ce sont des gosses qui
tire la sonnette 11 heures du soir les
gosses sont couchés je veux aller voir
et toi tu ne bouges pas coutume je fasse
il est arrivé malheur à germain je suis
sûr barre de temps prix restent calmes
je voudrais parler à monsieur julien
l'asnav à cette heure ci je suis son
frère
vous n'avez pas besoin de le dire je
vous ai bien reconnu
entré là je vais prévenir
ou pas
c'est le frère de monsieur pharmaciens
je suis dit d'entrer dans le bureau il
veut parler à monsieur à 11 heures du
soir alors là je me meurs si confrères
c'est dérangeant et demi pour venir ça
nous chez nous c'est qu'il est arrivé un
accident
la moto une ariane but dangereux on le
sait bien il fallait lui défendre le
s'en servir de toi petit savons faire
que je vais le recevoir
parce que tu as l'intention de leur
offre cette affaire là mondiale ce qui
permet aux garçons
mon petit gars aussi tu es bon enfin si
j'avais eu un accident ce n'est pas
parce qu il vienne vraiment pas venir et
d'ailleurs pourquoi se déranger mon
téléphone
ouais c'est assez incompréhensible
je dégote tu trouves un discret oui tu
ne manque pas d'atouts certains cure
qu'elles ont dû m'interroger moi tu me
le demande
ah oui à défaut d' excuses devraient
être ouvertement une explication
l'avocat s'est présenté à mon domicile
quel avocat tu ne m'as pas envoyer un
avocat non certainement pas tu vois
j'aurais cru qu'ils étaient des amis à
cause de ce qu'il sait quoi mon mariage
avec rosa friedrich pendant de quelle
manière parti quelqu'un leur a enseigné
la preuve
c'est une lettre de chantage
dans le meilleur style et il veut de
l'argent beaucoup
combien 59 rome novo selo
et pierre à voir
cette fois prudents
je vais pas me faire placer
ce que dit n'a pas de sens
avec la complicité d'un avocat marc
anthony
pourquoi la banque un but mais ça y est
tu espères sans doute me voir quitter le
vin moyen comme un autre de se
débarrasser d'affaires pharmaciens dans
le voisinage et déshonorent tu veux me
voir ailleurs dit ce que tu veux dire tu
veux me faire enfermer
c'est à l'asile parmi les aliénés ne
reste plus qu'à provoquer certaines
circonstances favorables mon internement
je m'abstiendrai de répondre je ne
poursuis cette conversation que par
nécessité
ce chantage me concerne je suis un homme
en vue pour beaucoup de gens ici je
représente le patronat
j'ai le souci pas réputation il ton
comportement scandalise explique moi ça
oui tu besoin de faire le joli coup avec
remercier la 50 on s'est entendus je
suis un sentimental un pourri que mal
finir
et maintenant que tu as fait payer avec
quel argent compte sur moi j'ai quatre
jours pour trouver la somme est ce que
tu dis donc
[Musique]
le chantage semman endroit qu'ils
exercent
je ne suis pas bénéficiaire sera leur
somme lundi en fin de journée
en l'espèce billets usagés de préférence
malheureusement tu porte mon nom je ne
l'oublient pas depuis plus longtemps de
toi alors rien je ne sais rien peut pas
attendre
est ce que tu faisais dans le couloir si
tu ne connais pas
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé mais je n'ai
rien compris haulotte avoir des besoins
d'argent ça suffit a expliqué une
conversation confidentiel mais bon tu ne
me dit pas la vérité
pourquoi
[Musique]
où
m
en acte cette musique et aspétois
[Musique]
mon kiff de ton avenir des études il
faut l'avouer furent décevants je
travaille à la brasserie rigoureusement
et le plus souvent à des besoins d'un
grotte je le reconnais d'ailleurs je ne
désespère pas cependant de la fortune
les examens ne sont pas absolument
nécessaires
un 18 ans mon père de deux garçons de
café pour réussir mon existence d'une
façon ou d'une autre il faut prendre le
départ
tu as toujours l'ambition de devenir à
chefs d'industrie
oui dans quelle branche
qu'est ce qui te plairait la bière a
bien évidemment tu a réfléchi au mariage
qui veut parier si ça se trouve en fer a
été remarquée on te souhaite pour gendre
quoi ça détonne notre ami quintin des
filatures on à venir et peut-être dans
l'haleine
je ne sais pas ce que tu penses de sa
fille la fille quand elle est plus
vieille que moi tu sais qu'elle est
charmant vous êtes ami d'enfance
justement j'aurais l'impression de poser
ma soeur venus pour rester entièrement
libre la décision ne devrait intervenir
que beaucoup plus tard
oui j'ai compris je constitue une option
c'était à beaucoup d'esprit mon petit
garçon part on dispose de leur
progéniture les parents ont le triste
privilège de la responsabilité
j'ai un peu trop l'impression de vous
appartenir la famille une famille comme
la nôtre représente la tradition de
l'entreprise
notre exemple à socialement une
signification profonde nous appartenons
au monde du travail et c'est bien
pourquoi nous habitons lusine nous ne
quittons pas nos ateliers pas une raison
pour devenir l'employé des quintin et
l'époux de la femme que vous avez choisi
bien c'est une façon de voir
je ne discute pas je ne suis plus un
enfant j'ai 22 ans et tu décides avec la
détestable autorités de l'homme égoïsme
de l'âme pour me trouver une petite amie
je n'ai pas besoin de tes encouragements
adorable petit garçon que je tente mais
le pompier tu peux faire confiance doit
te remercier l'exactitude scrupuleuses
les commentaires sont édités
[Musique]
d'où viens tu
mais enfin nous vient du pôle je lui ai
donné son argent il était absolument
nécessaire de le déranger
tu aurais pu le faire porter par sa
secrétaire ou envoyer un mandat par la
face à ce propos je voudrais te dire que
je suis très mécontentes
quand il s'agit d'argent ça me regarde
je la signature ne l'oublient pas on
vient lui a dû prêter l'oreille à une
petite somme
[Musique]
ce n'est pas vrai j'avais par à
l'affront j'en ai cherchés l'auteur je
les ai vus j'ai changé mon honneur et
mon père par nature je serais plutôt un
chanteur fantaisiste recommences tu sais
on souffle et jeanne homme de coeur
j'avais d'arbres
j'en ai cherchés l'auteur je les ai vus
j'ai langer mineurs et mon père je le
ferai encore si jamais à faire est-ce
que tu comprends ce que tu dis d'aragon
c'est écrit en vieux français
tu sais comme un soufflet conférera de
gueule
j'avais par la fin
on pourrait prendre un gin fizz de la
terrasse je vous invite à répétition je
suis là pour travailler jusqu'à quelle
heure je n'en sais rien ah vous voyez il
ya une chance chose de quoi peut-être
ensemble ne m'attendais pas cette
inutile
je ne sais pas quoi faire dans les rues
ce tournant entré chez vous non merci
pas ce soir j'ai assez vu ma famille je
me suis disputé avec ma mère avait eu
tort avec ma main il faut savoir se
défendre se défendre au vivant en
couveuse comme mon oncle réunion n'est
pas à plaindre
mais non bien sûr et tout pour être
heureux
lors du théâtre comme ça merci bien
n'importe qui joue n'importe quoi ton
dieu bondir savez bien 320 faut les
retenir c'est bien thomas stern je dois
vous quitter
alors au revoir
au revoir
vous en voulez
ma mère veut marier avec la fina
filateurs grosses fortunes mademoiselle
quintin vous connaissez non sur les
personnes très élégante jamais que notre
heure faut aussi qu'on ma fille s'occupe
avec germain laslades dans l'escalier
toute façon un jour ou l'autre vous
marierai
et des demoiselles qu'on épouse et les
autres sont pas présentables
tant pis pour moi
j'ai déjà donné ma réponse c'est non
pourquoi si elle est jolie parce que je
vous aime comme ça
ne croyez pas il vous faut une petite
amie pour passer le temps vous finirez
bien par la trouver il ya tellement de
suite d'une charge qu'à s'amuser
oui dans notre esprit à un peu moins de
bruit s'il vous plaît la scène est
difficile
c'est bientôt fini la répétition
je ne crois pas elle est la madeleine et
guillon sans doute
nous avons l'habitude de nous installer
dans une des chambres du premier étage
mais si vous devez revenir monsieur le
baron
j'ouvrirai salon rose du rez de chaussée
ce serait préférable bien sûr les
escaliers murs sont pénibles
non ici ce n'est pas l'amérique non nous
prenaient du champagne
il faut consommer je le comprend
pourtant vous m'excuserez madame je ne
suis pas dans un état de santé à boire
de l'alcool dans un cercle comme le
nôtre ces messieurs préférant
généralement conserver l'anonymat aussi
j'ai dit très clair les présentations
c'est l'habitude
nos amis sont certainement de pommes
société bien sûr je ne suis pas chez
vous comme au coin d'un bois
je le souhaite ainsi plus que je ne
l'espère don diègue et rope altier et je
connais mon père je sang coulait des
pleurs que je veux retenir le passé le
tourment et je crains la mer que
crains-tu d'agrium la puissante
faiblesse rodrigue allez courage
il a trop la jeunesse
il est trop amoureux pour tous vouloir
déplaire et de nous de ta bouchard est
simple on n'en mesure pas le téléphone
je viens tu vois mon petit articule mal
et par ailleurs je constate chez
madeleine une certaine tendance à la
désinvolture
tu vois je veux dire ma chez moi non
absolument pas donc vous avez prendre la
scène entre rodrigues et chimène
commencé sans moi tout à l'heure quand
je corrigerai
[Musique]
alors amos horev à sa belle ces permis
même recommandé à ton âge à sincérité du
sentiment n'est jamais ridicule à la
cabine monsieur l'asnav ne quittez pas
je vous passe monsieur la sna j'écoute
pas bons mais qui est l appareil
je ne comprends pas il est en avance
d'une journée oui oui
mais oui frères renoir
je
tu as un malaise
ça va passer
oh bien dit
le prévenir par téléphone
je sais par qui
anonyme venir de quoi
qu'est ce que tu as
je suis ému
pourquoi
m'arrive ce qu'on peut appeler une sale
histoire je suis la victime d'un
individu sans scrupules qui un maître
chanteur
je dois lui remettre une somme
importante faut payer payer
le prix du chantage l'argent est là dans
leur enveloppe et billets par paquets de
dix si tu as l'argent c'est sans
problème
j'ai peur
de quoi
je me sens menacé
aux deux choses inexplicables est-ce que
tu accepterais de m'accompagner
moi
c'est une affaire de famille assez
délicate la discrétion s'impose
tu es le fils de julien et on peut te
faire confiance je dois me trouver au
manoir comtesse à 00h30 avec l'argent
cette nuit tout à l'heure entendu ça
m'occupera
tu es bien la seule personne qui je
puisse demander ce genre de service un
tas dispositions représentent la
circonstance fortuite
le hasard imprévisible qui fait échec à
la machination termine je peux compter
sur toi
oui
ce qui m'inquiète c'est la facilité de
toute chose je suis conduit par
l'événement il doit être fait a les
idées
il faut continuer la répétition comme si
de rien n'était
éviter les questions embarrassantes
est ce que j'ai l'air normal
mais oui
à tout à l'heure
tu es bazin au téléphone je crois que
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un pour remplacer le
fils du terroir et arrive si tu voyais
la figure
je me fais du souci ni fils du quesnoy
et est incapable d'apprendre
j'ai bien l'impression que nous perdons
notre temps à répéter une pièce que nous
jouerons jamais que ne jouant jamais
pourquoi faute d'interprète
ça n'est pas croyable je suis un homme
qui a vécu plusieurs existences et
personne n'était au courant si ton père
les se tait c'est depuis 27 ans une
tente que je ne connais pas le mariage a
été pour moi une déception sentimentale
dont je préférais carte et le souvenir
tout de même avec le temps on oublie
heureusement j'ai oublié que tu était
marié
pas exactement j'ai fini par ne plus y
penser
[Musique]
dans la vie tout recommence la dren et
aujourd'hui ma femme une maîtresse
tendrement aimer l'autre est plus qu'une
ombre douloureuse je vis dans un climat
très personnel oui c'est particulier
[Applaudissements]
je vais tenir tête
qu'elle était morte
si tu considères que je n'ai pas de
moralité si tu estimes que goethe
entraîne dans une aventure suspecte
faute abstenir est encore temps pour toi
de renoncer
[Musique]
c'est tombé au moment de partir d'autant
plus qu'il ya peut-être des risques
on verra bien parce qu'elle est nocturne
notre escapade est dangereuse quelle
heure est il
mesnil 5
sors ta voiture
je vais manquer d'essence
la pente de la route d'arras est encore
ouverte j'ai ma petite réserve
6 litres ça n'est pas grand chose
suffisant pour la promenade
nous avons affaire 14 km très exactement
7 km pour aller jusqu'au manoir 7 km
pour en revenir
c'est que voiture je suis économe par
nécessité que tu m'aider
qu'est ce que tu fais dans son bureau je
prépare mon rapport pour la fédération
départementale le comité se réunit jeudi
prochain n'est pas dans ses habitudes de
travail et la nuit quand il le faut
germany pas rentrer
si morte d'inquiétude que du ton fils
n'est plus un enfant
julien nîmois la vérité il se passe
quelque chose je ne sais pas non je ne
crois pas la nuit est belle et germé en
profite
je ne peux pas dormir je prie ton caché
que tu fais une partie de cartes ont
caché les cas et une infusion
je vais te la préparer
mais vraiment tu ferais mieux de monter
dans ta chambre te coucher
00h25 sais quoi qui l'est de sanaa
dissimulé derrière un arm demande
raconte pas trop fumé veau d'or du tabac
donne la nausée que je baisse la glace
non surtout pas dans la nuit on pourra
entendre notre conversation
comment tu fais pour réunir la somme
me suis débrouillé il a bien fallu elle
continuait scrupuleusement je suis
régulier que je réfléchisse moi je
comprends tout cette histoire de mariage
le chantage et cette somme énorme à ta
place je n'aurais pas marché moyen de
faire autrement je serais allé à la
police dans une affaire aussi délicate
la police commettraient des maladresses
la police ne fait pas de sentiments ne
faut pas que mal le sache pour rien au
monde elle en aurait trop chacun préfère
ce qu'il veut tout pour le tout l'ons
qu'est ce que tu veux dire de
m'assassiner
il ya menace de mort sur ma personne
ton avocat d'en pousser ce soir 5
millions tu vas lui donner 5 millions ou
à l'est d'angers
encore quatre minutes
je connais pas ce manoir comtesse une
boîte ou non à nice
j'ai l'intention de s'en servir pour me
défendre
quentin qui envoya 26 mutation et il est
chargé pour bien rester quelques balles
pas de masters vallières
c'est une erreur tactique de se
présenter ensemble
le team va se méfier c'est le toit qui
l'attend tu dois me company sun je n'y
réponds je ne saurais pas quelle heure
est il 00h28
je vais descendre la première chante je
m'installe à une table je commande une
consommation tu viens me joindre bien
entendu nous ne connaissons pas pour ton
petit sol et pourtant je suis bien avec
le revolver dans ta poche à 00h38 cela
porte exactement dire s'il veut type
n'est pas là où l'attendait un gain de
temps fais ce que je te dis et ne tue
pas du reste
[Musique]
rappel
oh
vous
le faire
[Musique]
pourquoi pas une finale
je te défie sur personne et des soirs
comme ça pas un client ce cauchemar en
bête
bon je travaille à bruxelles
on ne va rien se passer du monde toute
la nuit on sent monsieur un verre d'eau
minérale
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]